[Applause]
home at last
and a joyful welcome for mahmoud hussein
after years in prison
multiple organizations campaigned for
his release
and say could open the door for other
journalists wrongly held in egypt
mahmoud's release can be a step toward
a loosening of the repression in egypt
there are dozens more journalists
in egypt in jail there has been a mass
crackdown
closing of websites shuttering of media
organizations
i think it's too early to tell but we
hope it will be a stepping stone
toward that mahmoud was detained in
december 2016
after traveling home to cairo from his
base in doha
he was accused of incitement
broadcasting false news
and receiving foreign funds to defame
state institutions
allegations he and al jazeera have
repeatedly rejected
al jazeera media network's acting
director general
welcomed mummy's release after a
vigorous campaign for his freedom
throughout his detention a statement
said
while he was incarcerated mahmoud had
become a symbol of press freedom across
the globe
on the day of his release al jazeera
calls for freedom of all journalists who
are unjustly imprisoned all around the
world
while being held at the torah maximum
security jail in cairo
mahmoud was kept in solitary confinement
for long periods
and did not receive proper treatment
when he broke his arm
[Applause]
reunited with his family and friends
there are other wounds that won't be
easy to heal
[Applause]
marmot's father died just over a year
ago
before witnessing his son's release
barbara angerpa al jazeera